تدخل الازمه التي سببتها خطه الرئيس
الفرنسي رفع سن التقاعد مرحله حاسمه مع
اقتراب المجلس الدستوري من اعطاء رايه
بمشروع القانون ازمه اجتماعيه دخلت شهرها
الرابع واصبحت الاطول منذ العام
اذا لم تسحب الحكومه مشروعها سنستمر
بالتعطيل الشارع يرفض التراجع وزخم
الاحتجاج وان انخفض نسبيا الا انه مستمر
وتقول النقابات ان فشل الحكومه بتقديم
تنازلات خلال الاجتماع الاخير اعطى دفعه
جديده للمتظاهرين
النجاح هو الانتصار هما مثل العطر والان
نحن نشعر بنسائمه فشل الحوار بين الحكومه
والنقابات انعكس على الشارع فمشاهد
الاشتباكات بين الشرطه والمحتاجين لم
تتغير اما العنف فهو مستمر في ظل دفاع
مستميت من قبل وزير الداخليه عن انتهاكات
الشرطه ورده فعل عنيفه من المتظاهرين بدات
تطالب اماكن رمزيه دخلها مكرو محتفلا في
السابق واصبحت اهدافا للمحتاجين الغاضبين
اليوم في هذا المطعم الرئيس الفرنسي
مانويل ماكرون بفوزه في ولايته الرئاسيه
الاولى عام 2017 لكن اليوم وبعد ست سنوات
يبدو ان مشهد حفاوه الفرنسيين بوصول رئيس
شاب الى قصر الاليزي قد انقلب راسا على
عقب مع قيم المتظاهرين باستهداف هذا
المطعم لايصال رساله الى الرئيس وداعيه
بان الحركه الاحتجاجيه مستمره وبان
التراجع غير وارد لقناتي العربيه والحدث
باريس